[موسيقى]
فطائره ام ار تي تي قادره على حمل 111 طن
من الوقود وهو رقم يتجاوز بكثير سعه
الطائرات المنافسه 45 طن من الامتعه وهو
رقم اعلى بكثير من منافسين وحمولتنا من
الركاب هي اعلى ايضا اذ تصل الى 300 مسافر
وهو يتجاوز قدره المنافسين
[موسيقى]
هي لديها قدرات فائقه ونحن نفكر في جمع
هذه القدرات التقنيه والاستراتيجيه في
مكان واحد اي جميع المهام السابقه اضافه
الى تنفيذ مهام لمسافات ابعد وتحمل عشرين
طنا وتقطع اكثر من ثلاثين الف ميل جوي وهو
امر لا تستطيع فعله اي طائره اخرى ناهيك
عن انها تنفذ هذه المهام بسرعه اكبر وعلى
ارتفاع اعلى
ان كان هناك من ميزه علينا ذكرها في
الطائره الحديثه فهي التناغم فالمنتجان
الجديدان يستعرضان مزايا التنوع في حلول
عاليه الاداء